the EPA is once again considering a ban
a potentially deadly chemical found in
paint strippers we reported earlier this
year how the Trump administration was
backing away from banning methylene
chloride the Obama administration's EPA
first proposed ban saying the chemical
posed an unreasonable risk Anna Werner
is here with the new developments on
this story and a good morning good
morning Gail and environmental and
safety advocates call the EPA
announcement significant it means that
the ban on this deadly chemical is now
still in play a ban they and the EPA's
own scientists say will save lives we've
introduced you to families whose loved
ones died from exposure to that chemical
and paint strippers the EPA determined
that the chemical methylene chloride
posed an unreasonable risk and therefore
should be banned but in December the
agency backed off well this week EPA
Administrator Scott Pruitt met with two
of the mothers in our reports and
yesterday the agency said it will now
keep moving in the direction of a ban we
spoke with Richard Dennison and the
Environmental Defense Fund who says the
family's stories were instrumental in
bringing change so you were worried this
was going to be delayed and then
potentially buried the families that
stood up and said enough is enough here
made a difference they were able to
appeal to this 2-part to members of
Congress on both sides of the aisle to
demonstrate this was not a partisan
fight between environmentalists and
industry it was something that was
taking human lives across the country we
spoke with family members of some of
those who died yesterday they tell us
they are cautiously optimistic with this
new development but they plan to
continue to hold the agency's feet to
the fire until this chemical is banned
for consumer and most professional uses
but this is a change from the EPA
because in December after December the
advocates said well we really thought
that this thing was going to be shoved
off basically into the attic where
regulations go to die
well you those family members you spoke
with and did those early reports what
they made a very strong and compelling
case these mothers told one of the
mothers told me yesterday she said I am
NOT giving up this is they're going to
continue to hear from us you know we are
never gonna give this up makes a
difference maybe it's a big difference
thank you Anna